I should say like coming from your roots
right yeah you used to work at a record
store yes
grew up in a regular store I had a crib
in the record store reading Source
magazine as a kid caring about bodies of
work you're a fan first right you could
tell that by how you rap some of the
people you work with right right how
much of like keeping your ear to the new
wave of what's going on or discovering
new artists are you still doing
uh because it's tough right it's tough
because it's a lot but you know I
I just kind of look at it as you know if
it hits my desk
you know yeah that's that's how I am
when it hits when if it once it hits my
desk
you know it's something to consider you
know and I just you know have my but but
like I said I'm like
I'm losing my I'm losing my opinion I
found myself becoming a Critic and I
just think that's all
as an artist
as an artist I don't think that's
healthy because you know me being
someone who can you know honestly say
I've I've influenced a lot of great new
artists you know like Russ you know
don't do it to tell me that I you know
I've influenced him I I can't
it's a diff I just found myself becoming
a Critic like who you know like called
like oh that's whack you know this and
that but it's like artist art
and
it's it's open for interpretation it's
it's objective it's it's not for
everybody it's for who it's for
and I mean these are just these are kids
these are these are these are people
you know just trying to make something
of themselves man just trying to trying
to be successful trying to leave their
mark on on the world so
I'm I'm practicing just
you know just being a listener versus a
Critic yeah I can't just at and as an
artist though you know what I'm saying
now see you know somebody like yourself
you know you kind of have that platform
to you know hold those right those
discussions right which is warranted
right we have to have that right because
it is you know it's competitive at the
end of the day it's it is a sport you
know yeah and it's the number one genre
music in the world so it's like exactly
so we're gonna have opinions people are
gonna right but I've just found it as
myself as an artist that could hinder
my my you know I'm worried so much about
how this isn't good for the culture that
I'm not focusing enough on your [ __ ]
exactly that's fair yeah and then you
get bitter and then you you know you
just I think it's funny how like
um throughout our whole life there's
always been
like some version of like the real rap
versus the yeah the commercial [ __ ] yeah
and it just keeps like Reinventing
itself yeah like error by Era yeah so
it's like you know 2017 it was that
SoundCloud Mumble [ __ ] yeah yeah right
and it's like I just feel like there's
always this like
conversation about like oh that's that's
that there's always a genre of a
sub-genre of hip-hop that's like easy to
kind of write off as like hey
but at the end of the day if you can
kind of
understand there's certain places for
everything like if I'm in the club right
I love hearing all this [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying exactly there's a time
and a place where if I'm on a road trip
right
um you know I mean I would love to
listen to Herbert exactly so I'm saying
like and then you look at you know like
the 2017 Mumble rap on Soundcloud these
guys are getting millions of views
they're getting millions of views for a
reason
no you're right you're right they were
getting a lot of views based on
everything but the music though that to
me that was like Peak Instagram antique
okay well then see that opens up a whole
nother there was like Instagram
influencers getting record deals in 27.
right yeah it was you know that's the
whole you know like but you know hey we
got through that we did get through that
I feel like we kind of got through
outside of the uh nft rapper that just
that was signed the Capital Records for
two weeks oh man you saw that guy yeah
the robot right Jesus Christ that was oh
that was wow that [ __ ] was crazy I'm
like bro like what is it I'm glad that I
was literally scared I got acts quick
though I was scared